for trophies await the winners for the
14th time the readers of the consumer
magazine Goethe hot which means good
advice are voting for the sensible card
so once again there were no muscle cars
or luxury sedans to choose from editor
venez edler says it's about things like
safety fuel consumption and price
performance ratio all very rational and
fast powerful cars have no chance see
how Alicia food winner in the compact
category is the Nissan Note the Japanese
compact features the largest interior in
its class from floor to roof it has two
thousand twelve liters of cargo space
with the rear seat folded down and that
with an exterior length of just four
point 10 meters and this son says it
consumes only three point six to four
point seven liters of fuel per 100
kilometers all engines are equipped with
a start-stop system to save fuel when
idling
you
Suzette's this son's Thomas House says
the note also has an incredible number
of electrical assistance unlike its
competitors in the segment for one the
all-round view monitor the vehicle has
four cameras that give occupants a
bird's-eye view of the car allowing you
to maneuver and park like in a video
game I'm gon is a Cuyahoga this year's
sensible sedan is the Skoda Octavia
optional electronic security systems
include distance radar and fatigue
detection as well as onboard proactive
occupant protection which does things
like Titan seatbelts if there is a risk
of an accident although the Octavia has
grown and offers more space than ever
before depending on equipment and has
lost up to 100 2 kilograms of weight its
fuel consumption is correspondingly low
skoda says the most efficient 1.6 TDI
green line uses only 3.3 liters of
diesel per 100 kilometers
school dashed it scooters email de la
bases the check company offers great
value for money I've got the goethe god
award shows that Skoda is making good
progress in positioning its brand and
products she says the cars meet their
owners expectations and are very well
received enough food and coffee and this
year's sensible mpv is the sea at lyon
st its lines are so elegant that you do
not recognize its practical side at
first glance but not only families
benefit from the spaniard spacious cabin
active singles might be surprised to
learn they can even stow a 2.67 meter
long surfboard in the lyon st for the
first time the lyon is being offered
with distance radar with automatic brake
intervention there's a choice of 10
power trains that all consume less than
5 liters of fuel per 100 kilometers as
with the Skoda the most economical
diesel burns only 3.3 liters and the
Leon will soon offer natural gas engines
two distinct a séance Daniel Cortina
says the firm has found the right
balance between driving pleasure design
functionality and usage and this balance
is what ultimately makes it's a sensible
car Amanda vas auto resonance
and like every year there's an
Innovation Award which this time goes to
Mercedes and 2013 a mercedes-benz
research vehicle drove completely
autonomously from manheim 24 time
without requiring human intervention
this long-distance driverless journey
proved that the vehicle can cope with
complex driving situations all by itself
with production based technology even in
heavy traffic in the future this should
effectively help correct individual
driver errors and largely prevent
accidents it was the second spectacular
pioneering journey on this 100 kilometer
route along which betta Benz took the
first long-distance journey in
automobile history 125 years ago deal
thing Ava had zip of Mercedes is parent
company daimler-benz says he thinks
Mercedes will introduce highly automated
system step-by-step not all at once to
improve the safety of vehicles to focus
economical and reliable yet affordable
these are the hallmarks of winning carbs